let's go
all right all right all right a few minutes away
from start time logiclivechest.com live i'm live
prep my openings done everything i could
for this baby done everything i could
i'm excited i'm excited i'm excited i'm excited
this has been my whole life my cousin has called
me every day on the phone and i i always forget
to call back because i'm just busy doing chess
every goddamn day i can't in a way wait for it to
be over but there's only two ways for it to end
and it's winning or losing and the latter does
not sound fun and i'd rather do something fun
and the words of mango people pog out that [ __ ]
don't know if it applies here but it is fun to say
it is wise words wisdom wisdom wisdom wisdom
i did play rocket league earlier today hikaru
roasted me for this apparently it's true i
did spend my morning playing rocket league
against atriac in a show match for a thousand two
hundred fifty dollars where i won uh in absolute
stomping fashion game one twelve to one which
just so you guys know is a record for atrialk
it is the biggest blowout ever um so everybody
clap for atrialk really impressive stuff out
there games two and three were tighter i
have to give him credit he brought it close
he doesn't know however that i decided to not use
the jump button for all of game three or the boost
button for all of game two he did not know that
which i think um if he did know he wouldn't feel
so but we won't bring it up to him that's a secret
that's a secret amongst us all right just.com you
guys you got to keep this secret don't tell
a triage it's going to hurt his feelings
anyway
let's just [ __ ] do our best today
played like four games this morning
did good i don't like to play before
my game like to take a couple hours off
i walked around i wasn't too hungry i got a case
of the the nervous yawns which i didn't know it
was a thing until this tournament which was cool
um but yeah we'll just uh we'll just come out
i can't wait till 18 months from now
when they tell the legends of two
soldiers who took the battlefield
one a little more active right behind every
step of the way but there has to be a loser
and it could be me and i think
thousands would rejoice but hear me out
it would be kind of funny
just a little bit if someone as brain dead as
me what a [ __ ] chess tournament so i put all
faculties in all resources in all of robert has
his knowledge magnus carlson's looks and now
bobby hall
eat [ __ ] i'm coming we got this
i cut my nails for this better tactility i
shaved my unibrow but i decided not to shave this
it's my playoff beard sorry to any nhl fans it's
uh surely not as nordic as you come to expect
all right we're starting
soon boys i'm gonna close out
keep it going oh my god
yeah baby that's what i've been waiting
for that's what it's all about magic time
wow
welcome back everyone to our coverage of
pug champs three presented by grip six
levy rosman hikaru nakamura we're here to swap
in for that amazing coverage earlier by alexander
botez and anna kremling hicaro were you watching
what were your impressions of those matches
yeah so it's great to be back doing doing
commentary after a couple of days the match
has been really really close so far i think today
for example this match between rubius and nico
extremely close it came down to an armageddon
game um also the previous match between charlie
and rayne wilson really really close charlie had
great opportunities to win the second game and
force a tiebreaker uh he wasn't able to do it
kind of nerves got him at the last moment but
nonetheless i think all the matches have been very
very competitive so far and i'm really looking
forward to this next match between logic and
ludwig it should be uh very exciting as well yes
let's show everybody the format once again before
we just kind of cut the chatter uh it's uh well
at this point it's a single elimination uh the
players play two games but the one difference is
that if it's tied one to one as we saw earlier
it's a five minute per player game if that ends
in a draw they swap the colors but the higher
seed gets the white pieces so if this next match
goes to that playoff ludwig will start with the
white pieces um let's also just remind everybody
what we're what we're all about here uh we have a
community outreach goal if you've been a returning
audience member you know what that's all about
whatever place a player finishes in as we get
that donation there there thank you for the
ten dollar donation we are matching up to a
hundred thousand dollars as part of chess.com
community outreach initiative you all know what
to do there's a donation button under the player
let's try to cross that 20k mark maybe hit 21 22k
over the course of the broadcast and then let's
just remind everybody who is playing who today
hicaro this first matchup ludwig logic i don't
know who to pick man i have like a slight inkling
for ludwig given his experience like right he
just survived that tense playoff versus moist
critical but logic's been great man hasn't he
he's played great chess yeah so i think this match
it could go either way i don't think there's
a clear favorite again like you i would say
ludwig is probably the very slight favorite
simply because he's had experience he played
in pogchamps one he was in the final match
of the consolation bracket where he lost to
charlie so i think the experience of anything
tilts the match a little bit in his favor but
again logic has been playing a lot of chess he
played very well against rayne wilson extremely
impressive in that final match in the group
stage so i think that uh anything could happen
yeah i am uh just looking to see
if the players get started here
all right so here we go oh what's going on i think
i'm gonna i think i'm gonna make a prediction uh
okay trying to figure out who i'm gonna bet on
i've made it better i've made bets on on ludwig
every every time so far so i think i'm gonna
make a bet on uh on on ludwig i'm gonna i'm
gonna bet um i am gonna bet 33 333 points on
ludwig i the screen sharing software that i use
to access the games i think just booted me
out so i'm going to have to reboot it because
all right that's never
happened before fantastic so
all right let me find a way to well
uh production team let's cut it to
uh someone else and then i will uh
the game is stored by the way it is a um it is it
is a scotch opening so ludwig correctly plays i
believe lotto is white right yeah so he correctly
plays bishop to e3 does not play c3 like xqc did
against uh moist critical in the previous match
where he played with c3 queen f6 knight takes
c6 queen takes off to checkmate uh plays bishop
to e3 which i think he is prepared there we go
we're back perfect see we gotta we we we wire in i
don't know if that's the right word the hosts and
i uh my you know producer shout out to uh to aaron
was like yo what are you doing and i was like uh
i thought i was ready but it looks like i was not
oh logic blunders on my uh oh no yeah and as i was
saying that our screen sharing software caught up
uh we've got a blunder oh man this is bad oh yikes
and this is i think the big danger i think um is
the opening fees when i've seen several of these
players like um logic and xqc in particular i feel
like both of them are very talented players once
they get out of the opening phase of the game but
in the opening phase if they get into trouble they
can end up too far behind to come back and i think
so far very unfortunate start for uh for logic and
i think ludwig should win this game he's up a
juicer already he's got two bishops in the night
against the fishermen tonight smooth sailing if
he takes care of business yeah that's so that's so
frustrating because as you said this bishop c5 is
a good it's a good line i mean it's it's i don't
know if it's the main line at the top level knight
f6 is also quite good but when you get this black
has to know queen f6 that's actually yeah i mean
queen f6 or even bishop to b6 but just understand
the idea that white can trade the knights on c6
and take the bishop on c5 yep exactly and then
there's also other things that can happen with
d6 you get your pawns tripled but um yeah so
um i mean very tough start i think bishop d4
here if um if ludwig plays bishop d4 moves his
other bishop gets his king out of the board i
think he's in great shape to take the lead 1-0
do you think well no actually i i was going to say
wow good move from from ludwig yeah very good move
the nerves i think what really hurt charlie
was maybe the fact that he was playing uh
ring wilson i think that's what really hurt him
because ludwig doesn't feel like he's up against
some sort of titan he just feels like he's playing
a guy that you know he can beat maybe that hurt
charlie that he's playing this you know colossal
type i mean i think there's something else that
should be said though which i think is based
on the way the pairings occurred and the first
matchup where rayne played against michelle carr
i think we actually thought that rayne was better
than he than he is because of the disparity in
the ratings so i think because he won that match
so convincingly um people sort of assume that he's
sort of a ringer you don't have much information
on him but in fact when he played charlie he
made many mistakes in the in the games today so
i think it's also something psychological or
psychological where because he played against
michelle in the first match everyone's like oh no
he's really strong he's really really dangerous
and um i think that made a big difference i'm just
drawing arrows one of my arrows has been played
okay i'm not do you like this move i mean i just
simplifying as long as he stabilizes like rook
v8 could be annoying you know there's tactics rook
b2 yeah i love c5 i think for ludwig it's great to
trade uh now it's a critical moment probably the
last critical moment i would say the game where
logic can maybe come back because if uh if ludwig
is able to develop the bishop and castle the king
or move the queen and castle the king and avoid
getting into trouble here he should win the game
trying to figure out exactly what ludwig is
thinking because if he gets too aggressive
with knight d5 queen b2 all of a sudden and um so
do we have uh cams on ludwig yet we do we do yep
he's not saying anything but we got good
music that's a solid move but
let's see if this is not bad
i just think that this threat although met with
this is results in a pretty fierce group here
which i don't know if necessarily is that
bad for me if i'm castling kingside but
i think normally in games especially around
my level the b2 g2 b7 g7 pawns are oftentimes
captured by the queen and that can be make or
break for either side for the capturer or the
uh the defender and why enter a situation like
that when i can just play a normal developing move
perfect spot on yeah well having
said that now logic can play roof
b8 and then it's very tough to see rook
b1 rook b2 uh if logic plays this move
you know ludwig okay he plays queen g6 so not
a bad move yeah there is this there is i think
i think ludwig can just castle here and on
bishop h3 play queen of three so yeah if
ludwig sees queen f3 then he's going to be doing
uh he's he's probably gonna win the game i think
as long as he doesn't get spooked he uh i was
trying to find exactly what he said about logic
there was one of the first or second days of
pogchamps where we gave him the big stage because
we know ludwig's gonna provide us with good
content okay g3 it's a move it's not the best move
there are some issues now potentially for white
but it still looks like ludwig is doing very well
yeah now we need this that we need that move
or else it's it's bad news you would love to
go f5 but that would that's right i would actually
think king h8 and f5 is one of the one of the best
opportunities here for black to try and get back
in the game because the only issue that white has
is if he castles the king to the king side there's
no bishop inside the sniper's nest so it's a it's
a very open light square diagonal and benji
fishy got into trouble as well when he hit an
open diagonal like that yesterday against daniel
negranu so that's the one big hope for logic here
so definitely not something like bishop e6 by
the way because even though you open up your
rook you don't need to leave white with the
only piece on the board that is a knight or
a bishop you've got to know some bishops you
forget played good move good move by logic
and again i mean it's it's obviously winning
for white with correct play but it's still
if you're ludwig you're a little bit concerned
because i think ludwig really wants to castle
uh king side and i think he's probably a
little bit nervous to push the f pawn here
yeah exactly f3 is probably one of the best
moves he might also play bishop back to e2
that would be a great move also yeah bishop
e2 just trades the bishop i th the worry is
that he plays queen d2 okay plays f3 after
is good yeah it's also good yeah queen d2
would have been bad because of bishop f3
and now i have a bad feeling the logic is
okay okay that's a good move bishop is a great
move now the question here is will ludwig see
the castle queen side and he does actually see it
which is which is important so it goes queen e3 i
think if ludwig can get his king castles at king's
side he's very likely going to win this match
that's what i would say the worst part is with
black it's like you don't want the double pawns
because you'd rather have a6 b5 and an attack
right but yeah the double pawns really make it
hard for black to attack and based on the texture
of where the pawns are um i think it's going to be
very hard for logic to create counter play here
i think ludwig is looking really really good in
this position yeah he i mean it's certainly very
good with such an early blunder i guess you just
i mean i scotch was the first opening i ever
learned and the amount of people i caught with
knight takes c6 is uh you know it happens to
you once and then hopefully it never happens
again right exactly yeah so i mean it's it's an
important tactic and i think that's i would have
suggested that logic played bishop b6 there that
would have been the move that i i would have shown
him um i don't know who he's been studying with
though to be fair so it's hard to be critical at
all and now ludwig gets castled and unless logic
can play f5 at some point i think what was going
to win this game yeah now it's really difficult
it's i mean at this point your your next strategy
is be as solid as possible and try to get up on
time but ludwig's even got a two-minute advantage
uh yeah ludwig is just crushing it right now
he's got a great position again the texture of
where the plate pieces are placed makes it very
hard for black to do anything here no pawn breaks
can't the pawns are double so you have no b5 to
attack the bishops the bishop on c4 is kind of
planted um i think i think white's white's doing
very very well i think ludwig should win this
game i really don't see where the counter play
is going to be coming from threat's now gone
okay he's going for this pawn he seems confident
she's completely defended at the moment but if
i didn't move then that's a threat exactly no he
sees it so that's that's what he's looking at here
so if i do move my night which is tempting
then he's gonna [ __ ] my [ __ ] up um which
is totally reasonable um that's like i don't know
that's the professional way of saying something
[ __ ] up i will push this guy right here
now we're very tight and now i can make a move
like this next turn uh threatening the queen
and this pawn yeah he misses he's missing
queen a1 that's the danger he's missing
queen all the way down and he's lucky it's
not mate i mean imagine queen a1 was made
right i think also for la for uh
for ludwig he's got to be careful
because maybe black can go c6 and d5 now
somewhere to try and open up the center
um again i think i think i mean whether if
logic finds c6 it's very unlikely but maybe
oh c6 is yeah of course that would be very nice
but you've also got to be thinking you know
he wants to play knight d5 and so i have
to play season but of course that would
be a trap man hey queen d6 queen c3 wow oh wow
whoa c6 is a great move here by um absolutely
fantastic move by by logic now it's a little bit
scary now and i would definitely be concerned
yeah that's a great move now
ludwig has to see queen d6 queen c3
yeah a lot that's a great move by logic and
now the problem is that d5 is a big idea with
pontics pawn takes a knight takes queen a1
and black is a very clear-cut idea push the
pawn in the center open up the diagonal to a1
that's why i really didn't like uh that's why i
really didn't like this uh this idea with b3 from
woodwork yeah a5a4 i mean i have some feeling a5
and ludwig himself might go a4 but then you know
bring the bishop back and but logic also can play
bishop g2 he might you know pick apart the pawns
and if you get one pawn then you get a second pawn
right right so my my guess here is probably
the best move is king king b1 is the safest
most practical move that that ludwig can play
plays rookie three i don't i don't dislike it
uh again the dangerous black will go
work d8 and push d5 at some moment though
yes the logic should say that rookie three
protects the knight so white can take the
pawn on d6 yes because you go why did he go
rookie three because you're looking oh queen
d6 i have queens and then you have to go oh
i see okay and then right exactly yeah yeah
another thing i guess white plays rookie
three like black should play rook d8
because you you both move rooks is white at any
point threatening some g4 and trapping this bishop
maybe yeah i think g4 is always a is always an
idea here i think logic has to go rook d and
after g4 ludwig is completely winning because the
bishop is out to lunch on the side of the board
um probably it eventually it's just doing nothing
useful it's just on the wrong side of the board
so if um if ludwig sees g4 after work to d8
i think ludwig will win this game but but
in general logic has to go rook d8 it is the only
move here where there are chances to keep the game
game alive ludwig almost up double on the clock
so 30 seconds more go by and um logic is going to
be down three to six which obviously also is not
in his favor he's got to go all in yeah he has to
play rook d8 here he has to it's the it's the only
move can he play queen h6 that would be okay i
would have liked the other work to dh just because
at some point maybe you want to keep the file open
although here you can also go rookie 8 and then
d5 so he does find rook d8 which is important
yeah if he spots this pin as well like he can
really start putting some ideas together here but
right so i guess i mean it's all in
ludwig if ludwig finds a couple of
very good moves he's going to win the
game without a doubt um it's like he's
trying to set up e5 this pawn push but then
pawn takes and your queen is under attack
something important to note perhaps worth
putting my king b2 soft very soft move wise
but since there's no dark squared bishop
it's pretty sound yes not the worst idea
ever but you are in the face of the pins so
and like right now this is like kind of like
it's like when i watch like better people play
chess where we are just improving our position
but we have no real actual breaks happening
until just then yeah that huh i just wish though
because if okay so takes takes takes
man he's so lucky queen a1 is not just made right
sure i don't think i'm missing anything oh man
well he might see it now right before he does it
if we just pull this up like whoa the bishop f5
is a really sneaky move yeah wow that's a very
sneaky move by um by logic look at that he he
notices the change in the position and he he's
man i would love it if black had these b and d
rooks that would be oh man oh no oh no oh my god
no way pontics pond come on logic take the juicer
no way logic might be playing this in a tricky way
like he's maintaining the pressure on d5 but he
if he takes knight d5 he'll spot queen a1 it check
me yeah you just got to go just take the pawn
what's he thinking about
like i said i have a feeling
he he he wanted to like trick a little bit with
this pawn but now he has to realize that taking
he has this chance because what logic
did there sorry what ludwig did there
on the last move is he he's cut his
king's escape right exactly yeah
he's just it's the only movement position
here he's got no time he's just got to do it
and then of course white
will play bishop takes and uh
ah i don't like eh6 here because now ludwig
should move his king 100 should move his king
yes d6 is a good move but not realistic at
this level um but he's got to move the king
here just king b1 or king b2 one of the two
moves even rookie five action is very good
yeah he did have it in his plans to play king
b2 i don't know if logic ended up seeing that
queen a1 uh keep saying both of their names
for the other person i don't think ludwig
saw that after knight d5 there was queen a1 but
oh he hung me oh oh no oh my god
oh he's a god oh he hasn't
he had no idea he's a god
what a god that is heartbreaking oh
my god no i mean it wasn't it wasn't
a godly move i mean he just he maintained
the tension there ludwig carl ludwig had
tunnel vision on the night move so he
just did it but he didn't oh my gosh
crazy oh that is heartbreaking yeah because you
know how much prep went into the opening there
ludwig's ludwig prepared that opening he got
everything he wanted he got the trick he got
the piece and then he just hung queen a1 man
crazy absolutely crazy oh that is absolutely
heartbreaking i mean that was like the one in a
hundred the one shot and a lot and ludwig just
kept missing it like even in politics he kept
thinking he could take like if he just kept his
queen any bishop 5 was such a great move because
if if the queen was any other square it was never
checkmate yep and it forced the queen back and
yeah we got to ask logic if he set that up somehow
if he was envisioning it i apologize uh but okay
i mean probably he just saw the idea that if he
could get the queen there it was made he probably
didn't really conceptualize everything else but
i'm sure he was aware that the queen got there
it's mate um but yeah there you have it that's
crazy favorite player just like magnus did every
day against wesley so in the last term he played
well on that note uh ludwig is gonna have to
uh lick his wounds and he's gonna have to take
that confidence that he got from this opening
into the next game because logic has the white
pieces he's gonna start with e4 we'll see if
ludwig goes back to the scandinavian uh which
he played against moist or if he goes back
to what he always plays but we'll be right
back with the second round of today park champs
three presented by grip six don't go anywhere
in a game where uh very clearly
um yeah chess.com if you aren't updated
i i just choked a game um shout out to
hess for uh for being nice uh and magnus
for the wise tip of playing king b1
king b1 or king b8 or b8 i guess is this way
which makes a lot of sense i thought to do this
earlier and if i had done that i would have been
fine too both would have been fine i should have
played that move i guess i did not need to play as
forcing of a move as knight but i thought i didn't
need to play it because i was going to move this
knight and if i'm going to move the knight then
why would i go here but then the obvious response
is well then that's why you go b1 and don't
waste a turn going b2 but anyway what are some
positive takeaways well i was up on the clock and
i was winning in the opening so i don't think he
has much opening prep uh and as long as i don't
[ __ ] up like that again i feel good about
game two and i feel really good about a 5-0
but did you see the the life vanish from my face
i was so um concerned with the bishops
or the night safety that i didn't think
well the knight is serving a role here which is
protecting a checkmate because this queen here
which has to be here because he made he
actually made a lot of good moves that
that made this happen right because my
queen wasn't here i was totally safe
but then this move which may be a better
response at this point would have been this
and then maybe he just goes for the check anyway
yeah but it's all right
whatever man it's a chess game
on to game two just as hard
i think the good news is i know the scotch
a lot better which means i probably know
this opening a little better and if i win game
two then game three will be my pick of color and
i think the scotch is pretty easy on a guy who
doesn't really know how to play the scotch but
we gotta win game two i
could just go out o2 a buster
which would be kind of funny
chess is the ultimate game of each
[ __ ] no matter where you are
too slow too slow i played really well i'm happy
with how i played outside of a game ending blunder
but all the greats have had game ending
blunders welcome back everyone to our coverage
of pogchamps 3 presented by group 6 a friendly
reminder which we uh tell you about feels like
whenever i'm doing commentary and then also
whenever i'm spectating right at this exact
moment you can play all of the bot versions
of these players uh if that last game gives
you any confidence go get ludwig bot he'll
probably hang main one um and uh at this point
he's gotta he's gotta win there is no more
time for yeah i mean it's it's very tough for
ludwig the good thing for ludwig again is he's
played in pog champs one um so because he played
a pogchamps one i think he did he lose uh he lost
him he lost the first game i think to somebody in
the bracket station he came back to win if i'm not
mistaken i don't remember against who but i think
he had he was in the same situation so i think for
sure um i think for sure anything can happen here
i think also the fact that he got such a winning
position gives him great chances um and you have a
lot of confidence it was just one it was basically
one idea that he missed that's all it was yes
he also lost the first game to moist critical
so we can't forget like he right he won the
game with white and then he took that momentum
uh into the armageddon and played white again
and his hit but now he he lost with white he
just lost with white so he's clearly been doing
some work on his openings clearly um i don't know
if he's gonna trot out the same scandinavian he
did play the scandinavian defense against moist
yeah i don't know what his his opening choice
will be i think um i think in general he's just
got he just gotta just play good moves just
just focus take a deep breath and try to play
good moves but the one thing i will say about
ludwig having seen him play a lot of chess on
stream is he definitely you can tell he's a
little bit shocked like he doesn't he's like
shocked by what happened in that game you can tell
he's focused but i think he really is in shock
um and so it's going to be interesting to see how
he controls himself i think you know in charlie's
case earlier today charlie was fortunate that
he got a great position in the second game
so because charlie was able to get the free
flow in the second game he's able to just blitz
out moves and get a good position the nerves and
like sort of the tilt factor didn't really matter
in the same way that that in this case ludwig
being black it's probably gonna be harder to
get to like move 10 just on moves alone ludwig by
the way has played uh the queen d6 scandinavian
so if anybody wants a very easy opening to
to play get get that scandinavian and uh
play this so someone's done some videos on i feel
like someone oh wait but you you recommended queen
a5 right lovey no i i i talk a little bit about
everything but thank you for plugging me yeah
that's uh great great see we're like volleyball
you know but but will he play asic okay he clearly
has done his breath isn't this exactly his game
against charlie was this exact opening but i think
charlie went bishop e2 and so he didn't go b5 but
in this case logic did put the bishop on c4 so he
did play b5 which is very good yes yes b5 does get
played and and i wonder if you know he's going to
play bishop b7 and then e6 or what he's going to
do the thing about queen d6 scandinavian in case
anybody in chat wants to know uh g3 is the way
to play this with bishop f4 and bishop here and
i mean people just don't know that and black
can get a very good position so it's one way
you can also play it the way that that um that
logic played it but not d3 where you go d4
and then you play for castles in an early rookie
one with knight g5 that's also very very strong
as well yes yes um but but i think it's also it's
harder because somehow i feel like when the queen
is on d6 it looks kind of scary like i i mean
it looks like the queen is just like it's it's
really near your bishop i think and
it just it looks scary optically
so oh no oh look oh my gosh logic just j logic
just gambits a bishop to start this game too
oh wow okay yo what is this guys guys is this
does logic think he can think he's bobby fischer
or something he can spot his opponent an extra
bishop every game that maybe i mean if ludwig's
gotta win now i i oh come on come on what's he
saying i want to hear this i'm up an entire piece
you go for it man you do you i feel
you bro but i'm just gonna go d8 man
i don't got to get custom you made this easy on me
i play fiance maybe play a move like knight
over here then if he keeps this here trade take
trade okay all right all good just a lot
just get your [ __ ] going queen moves
he's got a good strat he wants to trade the queen
he won't there won't be any long queen moves
and uh no he's right what he's doing it's
good now there is a threat here i think
he'll probably bring out his bishop if i know
anything about logic but i'm gonna go for this
yeah this i mean again what what oh knight c5
is a good move though by logic yeah great move
great move i mean i expect bishop c6 this should
be right then 95 and it starts to get dicey again
yeah because then ludwig has to find like
you know e6 he has to not play f6 for example
f6 would lose the game
actually oh my god you're right
yeah there's no king d7 at the end like bishop
c695 f6 queen h5 g6926 and you're getting mated
uh that would be so brutal no i mean you just
can't play f6 f6 is a move you just you know
you can't play but sometimes when you play these
matches it all goes out the window it's like when
you sit down in school to take the test you all
that studying you're like wait what then you do
something crazy so yeah i mean again all i'm
gonna say is this it's all on it's all on um
it's all in ludwig he has a peace advantage again
in the second game he's just got to um he's just
got to take care of business he's up a piece
now the problem though is how is he developing
his knight on b8 if white goes knight e5 that's
actually one of the big dangers um yeah i was
just saying ludwig has to play e6 right or even
then there's only move after 95 that i would play
there's also knight d4 it doesn't sound as
good but it's you know it's just in general
keeping the pressure up i think logic will find
knight e5 i i kind of expect him to because
there are no other real developing
moves you can play the rook to e1 maybe
but yeah he plays it okay i mean ludwig has to
see that knight c6 is not a threat and then play
e6 and he might go queen d6 he might do that
and then i think logic will play d4 right
it's the only move actually to keep keep all the
pieces on the board i mean it's very very scary
if ludwig plays the e6 he's he's pretty much out
of the woods i think because then his development
with the bishop and the king will help him and
he plays it very nice close he cannot fall for
the throbbing checkmate with like queen f3
or queen h5 here he's got to make sure to go
g6 on queen h5 and if clean up three just queen
off six yeah exactly just straight and the benefit
is that well logic might forget about bishop f8
takes knight i'm there is a chance he'll just
totally blank but um he also should not take
on c6 that's not why you move the knight to e5
right you know i think d4 is the best move here
and the idea is to play queen g4 following it up
with bishop g5 at some moment and if the king
castles you also have bishop h6 like all this
annoying stuff because yeah i mean logic is
playing not to lose cons considering he won
the first game so one and a half oh he's
going for the big cheese the big cheese
now if ludwig plays queen f6 here queens are
coming off the board and there will be no excuse
for him to not win the game yeah he he sees it
one move he sees it and he's trying to play f6 ooh
oh just go here hold up this [
__ ] is playing frustratingly
yeah he is you can just push don't push don't
just push push don't push push but if i push what
changes in the position well my king is no longer
protected so he goes check nice he saw it yeah
perfect great everybody benefits he yells a lot
he can take and then win the bit of the rook
so that's not the best move there you
go in fact how about we just make this
really obvious about what i want to have
happen good just play clean out six yeah
oh he said queen here oh oh oh yeah is that
the the way that he worked protect that
i don't know really good cheeky checks the
way that he worked that out out um not to do
the pun but the way that he worked out the
sequence i'm gonna go for it was perfect
literally perfect the way that he worked out the
sequence perfect queen f6 and absolutely perfect
that was uh that was super kept it very clean yeah
and if ludwig doesn't win here i mean he doesn't
deserve to you know to win the match i mean
because this one he's he's definitely got it he's
got it going here queens have to come off the
board he's going to be way ahead by at least
one piece so i mean this is this is it for ludwig
he's got he's got to uh he's got he's got to get
it done yeah for logic to now come out of this
without losing any material he probably has to
like take the queen and then take on c6 right
right and it's too limited just too limited
so i i think ludwig is gonna win here really i
mean the thought process there was absolutely
brilliant by ludwig the way that he worked out
f6 is the queen h5 queen e7 then realizing why
don't i make it really simple and really obvious
and now logic just hangs a second juicer in the
middle of the board yeah queen takes knight and
um and then ludwig is gonna coast to victory
yeah i like how uh ludwig's kind of taking his
time he he obviously saw that the queens could
get traded but now he's going to pause and
he he's just drawn the arrow to the knight
yep and that's it she just takes it that's game
over yeah he's looking at checks which we've
been threatening if it hadn't been defended right
because then my king is in a lot of trouble and
yeah perfect the way that the way that ludwig is
using this reasoning it out here is really really
focused about it again that's the case if they're
playing at a different level but i still still
feel like it's very easy to sort of lose your mind
and and panic after that first game which is like
what happened like and you just kind of want to
move really fast but one was being very slow very
methodical and he's really working it through yeah
like exactly he said f6 and a lot of us just go f6
oh that looks pretty good never in the
history of chess having ever thrown plus six
well but surely i could find out a way to make it
happen oh man it's like it's like those basketball
teams you know uh let it be a lesson no one ever
beats us by more than 30 you know 29. so uh no
he's got a point he deserves he deserves both
games frankly but he blundered that first one so
he just tunneled on one thing that's it he would
have won the first game otherwise so this is it's
very unusual i think where you see a match like
this where someone i think at least in the bracket
stage someone's been so dominant it feels like
where like this match should be 2-0 ludwig should
win this game and he clearly should have won the
first game but instead it's going to be 1-1 caro
there is like queen d4 bishop e3 take f takes
with queen f7 i'm like that's a very nasty trick
yeah well i i guess if i'm ludwig here i would i
would go queen of five personally because you're
ahead by a knight in a bishop you just want to
trade just offer to offer to trade your queens
yeah he uh he has to find this balance between
being like okay my opponent is completely
tilted he's just losing and giving me all his
pieces one of those pieces might be poisoned
so just keep it cool queen five easy move um he's
drawing a lot of arrows i mean he is okay they're
all gone now we don't we don't need to go look
but and uh hikaru he uh he plays queen f5 look
at that very nice move yeah real i i think ludwig
realizes that he's ahead by a bishop and knight
so it doesn't matter you just want to make sure
queens and rooks come off the board if you can
if you're gonna offer the trade so queen five is
the best move and logic either has to trade queens
or play queen d3 or queen e2 and neither
of those moves are gonna get the job done
so right yeah i think it's very likely we're
gonna have uh we're gonna have a have a
five minute game for all the marbles and
ludwig gets white because okay again yeah
knight she fired okay now just swap and
that's all she wrote that's game over
there is literally no way that ludwig is going
to lose this game zero percent chance yeah and
94 is a brilliant move too nice again try to try
to fossilize the knight on f3 you're hitting the
pawn on c2 and 91 is the only move and and so
yeah we're gonna have it we're gonna have a five
minute game gonna be really exciting such strange
games man i mean ludwig i keep doing i don't know
what it is about both their names they just they
just roll off the tongue like in an equivalent
way um logic played 97 against rayne wilson in
their first game in the group stage so it's just
weird seeing him blunder early it's just i
it seems like it i i suspect there there's
some nerves but also probably he hasn't studied
these specific openings i guess yeah bishop f3
just chops it perfect just chop it all off just
offer the trades after takes i would even just
play bishop d6 frankly just offer another trade
of bishops just reduce the material on the board
right because you know if you play like
bishop d6 and then takes takes on knight c2
rook c1 and uh-oh uh-oh no but i mean ludwig's
gonna win this game let's let's be serious
logic is thinking he's
thinking about okay gotta take
oh wow wow oh wow what a move by ludwig great
move very clean fantastic very very clean
and uh i mean i don't know if
logic is going to trade here
probably okay he does trade
you could set a trap a3
set that trump i mean because he's got a
c it's a trap you got to start thinking
creatively normally you play exactly so he
plays that but now he doesn't open his c
file so ludwig should just yeah okay easy again
don't make one move attacking moves chat just
because you can play knight c2 doesn't mean you
should then your knight gets trapped right exactly
clean clean clean clean doesn't even have to
castle king e7 okay he does castle that's fine
oh and to be clear just because i see some
chat is going insane there's no bias here
um i just want to see good chess and i feel like
ludwig was really unfortunate in the first team
he got a great position he was winning and it
was real heartbreak because he missed one move
um but there is no bias just to be clear for
everybody in chat who's going insane i i totally
want to see uh playoffs every single time um
yeah i do too actually yeah i kind of agree
you you do want to see that like dude that first
game yesterday between benji fishy and and negronu
like that was crazy i mean the whole comeback
and like i mean it was just it was great that
those guys it went down to the last 1.2 seconds
so right although benji tried to give everybody a
heart attack he should have just won the game yes
yes 30 seconds on the block it wasn't quite a 1.2
he missed a mate you know but yeah yeah he's
a fortnight the fortnite guy has got to make
it all dramatic exciting you know down to the wire
right and um okay rook takes pawn there's a little
problem the problem is black's knights can't
really get in the game easily if logic takes upon
d6 yeah please don't go rook t8 oh my god please
don't go rook t8 that would be insane what a move
and now you can laterally swing it to d7 or
e7 what a move yes rook d8 rushing with the
trade would have resulted in rook e8 you
lose a knight and then you're paralyzed
yeah that would have been that would have been
a serious throw so rook a7 is a great move yeah
also rookie seven is kind of a rook lift again
remember in his match against moist critical
he missed a rook lift so it's kind of like
and rick actually rick d7 is the best move
white can't sit white's gonna have to trade his
side straight off rooks here and then white's
left with one rook and and ludwig should win this
pretty cleanly yes very nice conversion from him
you know what's great is that every match has been
so close yeah like how many matches of knock i
mean sardosh xqc was 2-0 but that very easily
could have been one one yeah benji and daniel
legrando went to tire breaks niko and rubius went
to tie breaks this match is headed to tie breaks
um moist rain wilson moist was completely
winning right that could have very easily been
tie breaks too yeah very easily yeah it sucks
i mean it sucks those matches that you you
just have those winning positions and your your
nerves get the best of you uh it's it's gonna be
super i mean i know michelle is working super
hard i think her matches is the day after tomorrow
against mr beast uh tomorrow is is is who it's
tubbo uh tub over he has to be code miko code yeah
yeah called mikko i said miko sorry i'm a surgery
i thought you said nico although it's kind of the
same the same sound yes but that uh she by the way
she was grinding she did like six hours of chess
the other day man she got tired of losing i mean
she was like it's uh it's amazing amazing stuff um
yeah so i mean i think that's going to be a really
i that has potentially a close match i do kind of
think tubbo is a big favorite if i'm going to
be honest uh i think tubbo has like been been
bossing it uh he's been a little bit unlucky he
was a little bit unlucky i felt like some some of
the uh some of the matches were some of the bracks
were unfortunate because i was thinking about nico
um with an n and i thought that uh if she'd been
in another bracket there's a very good chance she
could have made champions and not been in the
consolation but because she was in the bracket
with objectively i think the two strongest players
overall is sardosh and benji she just like she had
no chance because they they both are so strong
um but i think if she'd been in another group
she could have been champions and i think in some
ways the same goes for tubbo too if he hadn't been
in the group with uh with logic and rayne wilson
i think there was a chance he could have been in
champions as well well here's the thing nobody
knew benji fishy was going to become a 1300
during the course of the tournament right
like that was insane uh yeah like that kid
first of all has clearly some sort of talent
for the game because his growth is insane
uh good coaching and hard work and that's it and
um you know he signed by energy and i said that
they should re-up his contract and give him a
bonus he'll be a chess creator for them as well
uh energy oh oh nrg okay yeah yeah okay
okay so they should uh i mean the man's
gonna like enter some i don't know
chess creator events right right yes
twitch rivals hand and brain you know that kind
of yeah yeah exactly okay all right okay so i
think i think 94 is probably a good move here for
for ludwig um let's see let's see what happens
it's it's mayday i mean you get made
it very easily can you two night off
good game so i think um
yeah now probably knight f4 again no real
stylemate possibilities the only thing white has
is one a pawn to run down the board not that it's
going anywhere but it's the one last trick you
have could play for stalemate with these
horses but that would take serious effort
but hey xqc almost got stalemated that first
game if sardone should push d4 toward the
by ludwig i guess you go a4 one last ho prayer
and a hope he goes rook a4 not a bad try either
trying to pick off one of these ponies um i said
okay yeah many ways for for ludwig to win here
if you go f3 there is obviously rook f3 although
you got to see that you got to see rook f3 you got
to not just move your knight and hang your knight
never over yeah it's never or i mean actually the
it is true though if you don't see f5 it is
kind of tricky to play here like king c2 now
you got to go kingston too then rook
d2 checking you can use the other pony
to make the chucks but okay now knight c3 and rook
d1 it's an arabian checkmate knight c3 and it's
the arabian mate here does does he i mean
he also can go rook d1 and then knight c3 so
yeah he but the thing is if he's not confident
after that first game he's going to think he
messed up and now he's going to go panic
mode and play like knight takes f2 which is
still winning right ludwig's been very composed
here he seems very composed and very measured
so i don't think he's just gonna panic here uh now
if he had like 30 seconds i could see it but not
with three minutes on the clock um i kind of think
rook d1 is the move he should be able to spot here
right because it's just like you know what they're
going to do they're going to take and then knight
c3 but so he had almost dropped he almost played
knight g2 check and i found it nice wow dude nice
move by ludwig very nice move yeah that's it it's
mate yep sick suck me very nice game bye very nice
strictly better strictly better there's nothing
else to say well how about this i mean we honestly
don't know what the heck is going on there we just
had two games where there was bishop odds by move
five six right like like we we need an equal game
hikara that's what we need yeah and i think we're
going to get a more even game in the in the blitz
game because i suspect that ludwig starts with
white so uh probably logic has spoken to his coach
or his coaches or and he'll have some idea how
to improve and not blunder a piece in the opening
but it definitely feels like whether it's just the
nerves of the bracket stage it feels like logic
is certainly he hasn't quite been himself today it
feels like just the way that he's been blundering
a five-minute game ludwig with the white pieces
because he's the hire of the two seeds five minute
no increment winner takes all we'll be right back
uh all right boys game three the only thing um
i can say is logic has some really good attacks
that if you're a great player and know how
to ford off empty threats then easy clap but
like he always has an attack that whole game
too he's down like what like two [ __ ] pieces
and i still feel like my dick's against the wall
so in a 5-0 i don't know if he can come up with
those ideas but i certainly will
have to avoid them i gotta piss
yo
so right off the rip i mean both
these games have been exciting but
um the fact of the matter is i am way well better
versed more well-versed in the openings and he's
still definitely in the game even after i've
been up a piece in both games within like
you know seven ten moves whatever
it is so i am thinking about that
welcome back everyone to our coverage of pogchamps
3 presented by grip 6. we just saw a one-to-one
head-to-head between ludwig and logic weird game
cecaro and now they have to play a tiebreaker
ludwig's got white five minutes what are
we expecting yeah so i think um in terms
of in terms of the five minute game i would
say that i think that ludwig was probably
the favorite again based on the amount of games
he's played combined with the fact that i think
logic has focused primarily on playing rapid games
he seems to be very methodical in his approach and
the way that he thinks on every single move um
for the most part so i think that there should
be a slight edge for ludwig that being said logic
is boasting you're not posting sorry beasting with
a 1202 rating in blitz chess i don't know yeah if
logic has played a lot of blitz or what's going on
um go ahead no i was going to say we got a scotch
and i was just okay uh did did logic prepare
something because surely yeah he did he improves
i i was sure he had an improvement i don't like
this line improvement line though necessarily i
still would have played bishop b6 yes the guards
i don't i thought the idea of bishop b6 and knight
f6 even if it's not correct at the grand master
level it's a simple free-flowing plan playing
queen x6 is much more double-edged that being said
look at ludwig he's deep in the tank if white
doesn't know what to do it can be very dangerous
for white as well but when you study this line you
got to remember what to do against queen f6 it's
the only move i mean there's bishop b6 but there's
also you know uh and we're obviously not going to
have any any throbbing checkmates but he i think
he's good at castles now we need we need logic
not to take on d4 too quickly to give ludwig
again very tough position for both players um
i mean personally i i think if if logic plays
queen g6 here it gets very spicy immediately
um the idea of playing knight g7 which is well
known theory at the top grand master level it's
a good move i think it's a lot harder to play
so logic is just going to castle's king to the
queen side which actually you know i kind of like
here even if it's not objectively the best way to
play it's a very simple plan yeah so he i think
he's gonna he's named snap castle the problem is
between the two players one guy's got a stack
of pieces in front of his king and right
ludwig might just snap off b4 without even
thinking and that would make the game insane
but logic has got to move here yeah he's gotta
go you just gotta go yeah one thing i would say
as well as when he played the armageddon game
against rayne wilson when he got really low on
time he just panicked and started going kamikaze
mode he just hung a bishop and then a rook
um and so i think it's imperative for logic
that he doesn't get way behind on the clock
at any moment here not more than probably a
minute yeah i'm literally just gonna say if
you're playing a five minute game for anybody that
wants to kind of set yourself these uh these kind
of time frames it's like 40 seconds one minute and
don't watch my speed just championship matches but
um for yourselves you should try to keep like a
comfortable barrier in a 15 minute game car would
you say like four or five minute barrier like
at most two three minute i think it all depends
on the level i think i mean i think the grand
master level if you understand the concepts or
it's like one move if one if you play one move and
there's a tactical sequence that wins the game you
can essentially use as much time as you need to
like five or six minutes five to ten minutes even
but i would say at this level probably not
more than two to three minutes on a single
also i would say as well um there is another there
is another remedy to problems levy which is that
if you're if you really are worried about your
time usage you can uh download a google chrome
extension with levies voice and my voice as
well which will tell you to move you can set
it to like five seconds 30 seconds um or minutes
or percentage of time so there's a google chrome
uh download which the players might want
to uh use if they have the opportunity
or an extension sir i did not think that was where
you were going with that i thought you were going
to say check into therapy but yeah that's uh that
that extension might honestly give you there uh
might make you have to check into therapy
yeah shout out to jack lee that guy's that
guy's always coming up with new and creative
ideas he uh he found a way to beat a bot only
by pre-moving on chess.com and it forced them to
like recode the way the bot plays but i love queen
a4 by largely even if it's not the best move i
love it it's aggressive oh no no no no although
i'm not taking him with the pawn there oh he
might play king b8 dude he might play king b8 just
oh my gosh queen tunneling he's just
tunneling the whole queen side oh man oh
now he's got a really just okay b6 queen
eight is made and oh c6 it should be six
that's actually i don't hate that move man i
don't hate that move and if black can get the
knife to f4 he has all kinds of threats with
checkmates yeah that rook is guarded and it's
getting closer on time it's about 10 seconds
now okay we went a lot uh willing to ludwig
he just takes oh my gosh sure d2 work
takes knight he hung his knight takes night
oh no rook takes knight oh no oh my gosh that's
insane wait let's let's just bring that back um
oh rook takes knight and now queen
f2 queen g2 is just game over
like yeah and oh and he's
queen of two oh no oh no oh no
queen f2 logic misses it queen of two
oh no the only one oh we missed it
and now he's right because me ludwig has a force
made in two and now he's mated what a throw
king eight and then queen c8 and there's
actually a staircase checkmate oh man logic
through 87's mate mate rookie sixth grade seven's
queen d7 there's three mates here for white
oh my gosh oh what a huge throw let's go
i was scared for a moment there was some f2 action
oh he sees it yeah it doesn't matter his chat's
gonna definitely tell him now for sure no he said
he said he was scared there was f2 action so he
he must have seen it that is completely insane
rook d2 queen f2 that was that was entertaining
but i feel like i just lost some time off my life
i mean that was uh that was just so stressful as
a spectator if you were a fan of of either of
those two and now the worst part is it's not
even the group stage someone is going home
and um so we will bring in the players for
interviews don't go anywhere park champs three
percent of my grip six returns in a moment
ah got rid of you early just wanted to
say hope you have a nice stream oh yeah
thank you bobby i remember reading that
i remember reading that [ __ ] thank you
dude for reading your host earlier
appreciate it man white to move yes
black to move
no oh cause white's there
do i sacrifice my queen ah i do okay take there
this takes
oh this is a tricky one
maybe it's not that tricky actually
if i go here it's out of here
do
uh-huh
free
what is what trying to do here
oh i don't know that's black all right i what
chuck here that's just taken though
take here and that goes there and then i go here
this guy ah yes uh
you can check
take here
welcome back everyone we're joined now by the
players and uh you know i always start with
with the winner but i honestly ludwig just before
you got here i was talking to logic briefly and
i was like that was you know i was like that
was that was rough like how you know and he's
kind of telling me i just want you to tell me to
tell tell everybody what you told me man because
your mentality through all this you know people
people in a game like that would be stressed angry
your mentality is very different so i mean i'm
going home to a fine ass woman and a baby so
i'm happy i mean and at the end of the day this is
for charity this is my first time and i i wouldn't
want to easy win like it was very you know he
played really great and yeah there's nerves that
come with it when you have thousands and thousands
of people watching you it's not like performing
that's easy that's what i do like i say like i'm
a rapper i'm not a chess player professionally
even though i love the game so there's things
that i miss there's things that i still don't
see and i don't necessarily see it as a negative
you know because people could be [ __ ] boys about
it and try to be like oh you lost or you this
or you that's like no i won i made money for a
charity and i'm happy but i did take a l to my
man's bloodwork today so i will wholeheartedly
admit that um but you know missing things like
like in this in this last game with the with the
mate in two um it just gets me more excited to
further learn the language of chess and have the
vision for it so at the end of the day it's like
we had fun um you know it's all going to charity
and hopefully you guys will let me come back
because i'm about to be i'm going to be on it now
ludwig congrats man now you got you got to top
that off man how do you feel how'd you bounce back
is two matches now where you you you start
with the with the oh one what do you do to
what do you do to get hyped up motivated to to win
it after taking a loss in the first game i think
logic is is uh i mean a hell of a public speaker
but everything he says is uh is resoundingly true
that like i got checkmated on on a1 and i will
that will never happen to me again and so the
biggest takeaway is uh i've improved my game of
chess so that's i can uh i can i can take that
away but i felt good after i got a dm from hess
my best friend magnus we were chatting a bit about
like you know thank you uh yeah where finland is
on the map um but i felt fine because um because
i was winning in the opening and i i think that
was where i cause i don't know dude logic is crazy
man it's like no matter what i did he always had
an attack and it was terrifying that i was up six
in game two and uh yeah second game i really did
mess up with that bishop and i should have just
brought it back for sure but i don't know why it's
like saw that square i was like i'll be fine here
and your night ticket is hilarious yeah it was
an early lead and that made it feel better but um
i mean hats off to you because it did not feel
good um one getting stomps game one and then
game three was terrible i felt terrible the
whole time i started just nod in my stomach
well hey caro we were we didn't know who to
pick right beforehand i mean this was such
a tense match i mean i think hikaro would you
say that logic played like the best game start
to finish in all the pog champs like that first
game against rain that's why we just didn't know
like yeah i was kind of curious actually in terms
of logic it must have felt much different than
when you were playing in the group stage because
your accuracy and just the general general moves
that you found they were a little bit different
it felt like that you made some mistakes today
and did you feel there was a difference between
when you were playing just prior to the bracket
stage just playing individual and trying to figure
out which group you would end up in or was it all
kind of the same and it's just like things
just went a little bit differently today it
was kind of the same i just think i i knew that um
ludwig is a really good player like i feel like we
i feel like take all the pressure away and it
would be like fun to just like play against them
i think it would be like really good matches
in general um but having never been involved
in a tournament or anything it was
like yeah like nerves but not even like
oh i'm scared it wasn't like that it was just like
oh [ __ ] i got to think about all these things
that i usually don't think about like time really
matters and if i do this and if i do that and then
you just kind of start overthinking it but that's
how i was when i would rap you know it's like
i'd be on stage and you forget a word and you
beat yourself up about it and you practice and
you practice and you practice and you practice so
that those mistakes don't happen and those jitters
don't necessarily happen anymore i'm excited for
that to continue with chess and even outside of
pog champs in itself like i want to play as many
tournaments as i can like this fun and it wouldn't
be as fun if it wasn't as challenging because
of you know having a fantastic opponent who's
a really good player i think that's a very very
good mentality well we got we got ludwig you're
you're going into the semi-final yeah um you know
there's been a lot made of the different players
involved in the semi-final there's it's a lot of
players you yourself i heard you on a stream one
say you thought you might be the worst player
in the champions bracket i don't want you to
think that way we got logic here he's hyping it
all up you're in a semi-final with rayne wilson
and benji fishy saying it out loud doesn't change
the fact i yes exactly what you said i am in a
semi-final with benji fishy a 16-year-old
cracked genius sardoche like a 1500 man
and then reign wilson i am not sitting pretty
in this tournament but uh look at the end of the
day uh i think i've been more nervous for
this pog champs than any other pog champs
i don't know why even my poops have been weird
today and i think it's because i've been nervous
i uh we didn't all right well i'm just letting you
know that this is what pogchamps is doing to me
it's sucking my soul away levy okay all i can do
is go out there and play the best chess i can and
if that's enough hell yeah and if it's not
then shame but that's all i got all right
well on the note of ludwig's fecal matter
we're going to thank you both for the epic
games today uh logic i'm sure chess.com will have
you back for anything chess related in the future
music related uh maybe you guys can do uh some
sort of music thing as well i know ludwig did
like a christmas track so that'd be pretty dope
dude don't tell logic about my christmas album
yeah we should just start a rap group it was
good i'm down i'm down we gotta i do a holiday
i'm a holiday guy only you know love him come on
it was so good give yourself some credit yeah all
right ludwig best of luck in the semi-final logic
it was amazing calling your games thank you both
and uh we'll see ludwig we'll see you
in the semis peace out good games man
bye guys all right ikaru we've got we've got our
champions bracket semi-final how's that looking
man yeah i think it's going to be exciting
i think um you know i think the thing is
you see little cracks like little chinks and the
chinks in the armor as we say um where was sargo
i think we all thought he's just amazing like
just grinding shots 10 hours plus every single day
and um he basically keeps uh he was playing
really well and then when he played uh
benji benji kind of cut through cut through
sort of the armor do you want to call it he
just cut through and uh and he beat sargeras and
xqc got a winning position against sardos as well
so um we're we're starting to see you know
that anything can happen yeah absolutely uh
i think ludwig should be full of confidence
i mean he's also going doing good training
working on his openings and you said it best
i mean i've got nothing else to add we've seen
chips in everybody's armor so this is exciting
we've got one more matchup coming up today between
pokemon and uh myth but first we're gonna take
a short break and tell you about our official
sustainability partner for this event chat you
already know what to do you've been here for
you've been here for a while give a shout out
to guayaqui and their 25 years of regenerative
yerba mate spam that emote in the chat
for a chance to win and uh we'll be right
back four pillars of regeneration to heal
all nations we work with and not against
because we are a part of this we've never been
apart from this our hands feel through the soils
past our feet touch on the blades of grass raid
all these voices into a beautiful tapestry find
those similarities we all share in these breaths
that we breathe this home of ours sustains us but
needs us so together we'll move through this
long night and inspire us all to come to life
encounter when i close my eyes i can almost
um
you make me
ah
i'm playing blitzy oh we could go off
emote only since it hasn't started yet
oh whoops oh dude i need a
okay dude all right here we go
your breath again fill up my
i'll lungs
i remember you
um
hey
all right moving this up is bad
oh
there's a distance between eyes like slower left
out the name of the game baby speed chess or speed
ah
actual accidents
can't afford it oh no
again
quack quack
hey me again luscious larry leather
browns sweaty heavy pocky leather wow
no wait don't kiss him i'm your son i'm
here from the future if you kiss him i
won't exist so please hey i love your
belt is that what you wear in the future
oh rad totally what my grip 6 belt i
know right i love this no flailing flaps
bulging buckles or hideous holes and with
a lifetime guarantee you really can't go
mother whoa
welcome back everyone to our coverage
of puckchamps 3 presented by the amazing
american-made grip six they've sold out of all
of their chest themed wallets but they're because
they're super popular obviously uh in fact i
got one uh but uh before pogchamps is over you
can check out their belts their wallets their
socks i'm wearing some right now hicaro are you
yes you are no i'm not right now but i do have
them sitting on my uh chair right well we don't
we don't need to do a live demo i do have them on
they are the short ankle red ones very comfortable
not going to tell you how long i've worn
them though because that would be terrifying
uh but you can check out go.chest.com grip6 use
the code pochamps 20 get 20 off but let's also
tell you about other percents off and percents
and what's going to charity we all know about the
community outreach initiative which is actually
hikaru why so many of these players even played
because they thought it was great they thought
they would play some chess learn some chess
and give away some of their winnings to uh to
charity and every single person whatever place
they get that percentage equal amount will be
donated to the charity of their choosing so
yeah correct that's a little feel-good moment
there as we've got one match remaining your
thoughts on pokemane versus myth so i think this
is probably the match where there's uh out of
all the matches i've seen in the constellation and
the championship bracket where i think objectively
there's probably the biggest mismatch um but again
we we play the game because uh if we didn't then
we would have already just handed the crown to
sardosh i think before the event started and
yes while sardosh is looking very good in the
champions bracket he did lose to benji fishy
and um and of course he still will have to
beat ludwig and or beat benji to to win the
championship bracket so that's why we play the
game but if i'm being truly objective i do think
pokemon she's been putting a lot of work she
came very close to taking a game off of xqc in
the group stage um she beat rubius so i think
the pokemon is the clear favorite in this match
yes uh her kind of growth her games against uh
xqc even very like very close that second game
up a piece has to fill in the gaps uh so she's
actually not streaming she's going full focus
a myth was putting in some work with uh
with maurice ashley his openings look great
uh so i do think that pokey is if i have to
give the not to someone it's it's uh it's
pokey but we're about to see myth is finishing up
a game uh and just also want to give some love to
a few folks uh the shanpai uh d'amsa someone named
anonymous someone anonymously donated uh super
caught and uh daylighter and zombie lawyer they
all donated daylighter in particular donated a
hundred dollars you guys can use that button below
the video player uh and i'm gonna read this out
because he shouted me i feel like i don't want
to do no wall him even though it's not my stream
crossed a thousand rapid today just in time for
my birthday so thank you to daylighter also said
gotta thank levy for the danish and the dutch
videos you're welcome uh but uh thank you for
the 100 donation that's huge oh we got moves
they just started them asap my god they just
they didn't even wait myth was done they just got
him in and and here we go so we have a game we
have the london system yes and knight c6 another
guy who's going for this knight c6 they got to
start moving that seat on that's what they got
yeah so i i think again myth is playing playing
for the opening setup that i recommended to um
uh xqc yesterday i think it's pretty reasonable
um but we're but already myth is thinking so he's
kind of channeling his inner xqc and thinking here
very early in the game um but he has to have been
ready for the london system because pokeman has
played this i believe every single game so far
yes the thing about the london is that you can
prepare for it you still need a line i mean i
listen i once had to play eric rosen in a match
where he only played the london i didn't help
my cause it was annoying um i also just want to
quickly give a shout out to actually to chester
to our very own chess play with the 250 dollar
contribution chat so uh do we these things kind
of go one after the other i think that you know
once a few people are are giving to charity
that uh we'll have a we'll have kind of a
snowball effect but she goes for this bishop
b5 again i love this it worked against rubius
this night yeah i think it's a great opening
choice okay so a6 so she takes probably you
just play knight d2 and c4 here in 95. oh she's
going very good move he's just going for it uh
i hope myth doesn't play queen d7 and i to be
honest also hope he doesn't play queen d6 so
queen d6 is a very tricky move but yeah i i think
we'll see what happens here and um i made my bet
so i i made my bet the odds were too good so i
i had to i had to bet accordingly even though i
think i'll probably lose my points uh it was good
value that's okay do you think it was good value
that gamestop went up to 200 today it's 181 in
the in the after hours market but anyway that's
a topic for a whole another day yes uh trading was
halted you know when it almost quadrupled that was
good that was good it was a nice little ending to
the day yeah that that now unfortunately what that
means is that probably for the next like two days
at least until the weekend all streams are going
to be inundated with non-stop diamond hands total
and all this other all this other nonsense yes yes
yes but ethereum looking good as well you know
uh but we're going to talk we can talk crypto uh
at a different moment myth has gone like this i'll
reiterate what what charlie munger said today here
at the conference in la which is that it's sort
of the uneatable combined with the unspeakable
that's all i'm gonna say okay what does that mean
i don't know i'm not charlie monger oh okay fair
anyway all right i don't know i was like i was
like am i dumb like do i not i don't all right
all right i yeah charlie monger there we go that's
anyway all right um pretty good start for for
for pokemon she should probably take the pawn
or play f3 both moves are very good here i i
mean yeah i think knight c6 because she's
going to be like am i missing something so
we're probably going to get knight c6 queen
please don't go queen d6 so just queen d7 i
don't want anyone move blunders i'm done with
one move blunders um hey queen d7 95 queen b5
like yeah i mean i think it's very unclear what's
what's happening it's i think white is up a pawn
but there's a lot of a lot of tricky opportunities
here for both sides a lot of possibilities
mitch just has two queen moves so one is slightly
more active than the other he's got four queen
moves to hang a queen so he's got two queen
moves and right so i think i mean he can go he
can either play queen to d7 or queen to c8 i think
27 is more more likely just because it's natural
move uh bringing the queen more into the game okay
knight drops back an hour will he follow the path
follow the yellow brick road out to b5 very scary
move at the same time i kind of think it's likely
that he will because he wants to go forward
i think when you're new to the game pushing
your pieces forward it makes a lot of sense yeah
see queen a4 is the other move here that i think
is very possible but i think one of these two
moves will be played i just don't know which one
especially because some of the players have
click on like they oh my god he almost played
f6 he almost played f6 and now he um yeah how he
plays queen b5 good move yeah very good move by
meth beautiful he hits b2 and that stops white
from castling now pokey seems like a sis like a
system player she really likes to get kind of a
nice comfortable position that she that she can
mess around in and make things happen but she's
already dealing with some very serious threats
and myth is dealing with a red bar connection
what's going on with myth oh it's back back yeah
all right she's
let's see what she does here i mean b3 is the
best move i could see her playing queen c1 also
yes when the queen comes out you've just
got to look straight down what's under
attack b2 uh definitely pawn push is the first
thing you think of and as you said queen c1
but she might go knight c3 but that's a lot of
options here a lot of options um for pokemon in
this position i think i think if she can get
out of this opening stage the next couple of
moves without making a blunder i think it's
very likely she'll win the game because i
think for myth it's very hard to develop here
um it's very hard also with the queen in the
night a lot of pieces out in the center they
can be attacked very easily i think the next
like probably three to five moves will be very
critical in terms of uh who's gonna win this game
yeah honestly just a tense moment i mean we've
said everything there is to say about this
position chad how are you all doing you guys
are uh energetic it's been one of those the
longest broadcast of pogchamps we ever had double
header we had to switch commentators it was uh
you know it's been an intense day uh i
was here so i anna doing her first uh
commentary saw anna cranling that is
she does play knight c3 by the way so
queen b2 is she gonna take on d5 is that what she
saw i'm not sure what she's gonna do here i um
yeah i'm really not sure i think anything
could happen but i think 94 is much more
likely objectively just take on e4
and then castle something like that
it almost reminds you of the rubius game when
like his queen got in here and then he like
left it and then he brought in too many pieces he
didn't develop everything so myth needs to press
the button stop it and then but yeah very very
tense moment though very very tense for both sides
do we know if if if poki's been practicing
with like her pokeman account and then another
one because she seems she seems above this 700
elo um yes i i will say that i think like most
other players in the event i do believe pokemon
has a second account as well which she has been
playing on i haven't looked recently but um but i
do believe she has a second account okay in fact i
think most players do like i do believe also as
an example i believe that rayne wilson who has
played a whopping total of something like 20 games
um on the account wearing wilson i'm pretty sure
pretty sure that he has another unnamed uh
count on chess.com yeah it just seems kind
of crazy that a guy you know only played magnus
like three years ago and then is uh yeah he's
definitely up there in terms of skill uh uh we got
queen b2 by the way so pokey plays knight b5 man
this is gonna get removed from pokemon really
really good this could get really bad really
quickly because myth doesn't have a check they're
both covered is he gonna play knight c3 oh my god
i mean i don't know what he's gonna do here but
yeah we'll see very very soon we'll see he might
play rook c8 i mean he might just see knight c7
and just play rook to c8 that also could happen i
really want to know on uh he's clicking around he
sees he saw e6 which by the way might be like some
sort of brilliant sacrifice crazy attack maybe
yeah i mean and if you really can't spot here
if i protect and attack
oh don't go back to b5 knight cc oh that
would be no no don't go to b5 don't go back
could go to b7 true true
oh good move by myth good move the problem
here however is that i think in this position
um what's gonna happen is once pokemon castles are
king yeah myth is in very bad shape because it's
very hard to develop that being said e6 here would
would actually trap the white knight and then it's
gonna be very hard for pokemon to respond here
well does she have to play like rugby one or
knight c4 sometimes uh i think probably c4 and
go for queen a4 although queen b5 unfortunately
now allows c4 immediately because the knight
protects c4 if pokeman finds c4 i think she's
well on her way to a victory yeah otherwise queen
b5 is a fantastic move like finding c4 that's the
difference at this level it's the gluing of the
position seeing although to be fair levy there's
a very dirty idea knight takes c7 rook c7 rook
b1 i think with an idea of rook be a chuck mate
maybe it's not maybe it's not a force
checkmate but it looks very dangerous as well
yeah that king on e8 really
looking a little bit suspicious
she needs to also not do the thing where you get
like tunnel vision like knight c7 she doesn't
need to go like knight f7 or knight
g6 or any of that insane stuff
uh but right now when you see this you think
they want my knight you look at check exactly yep
no checks no captures you gotta find this
move and you gotta realize it's guarded
and yeah we don't we don't have we
don't have pokey screen so we don't
know what arrows she's drawing so can't
move you gotta find c4 maybe she goes f3
another option it's possible i still think c4 is
very very likely here um but not sure oh goes f3
good move though it's a good move because again
for mitt the problem is he has no development so
even if even if objectively there are easier ways
for white to win the fact that myth does not have
any development the king the bishop and the brook
are all in their original squares work on c8 it's
not on its original square but it's not an active
piece either i'm very very afraid from it and now
myth has to not make the mistake of being like oh
she wants my knight i can't let her have it like
don't just take on d5 dude you know um white's
advantage rests in the fact that white is castle
like if black gets e6 bishop out castle black
is fine so exactly stressful like myth needs
to not go i gotta move my knight and then start
getting even more delaying in his development
yeah exactly so i mean i don't know i don't know
this has been a very slow paced game compared to
that those last two and he just takes on d5 nice
nice queen takes
okay so of course she can take she also does have
c4 again i think she'll just take the knight of
course and if if pokeyman can see pawn to c4 again
this is what the whole game hinges on will she
find pawn to c4 that being said queen takes pawn
on e4 was a really really nice move by myth here
yes um but but the problem i think for actually
for myth is that for pokemon she should see that
the pawn is under attack from the queen and the
bishop on the diagonal so she pushes his pawn
forward i think she again if she pushes the c
pawn and sees the idea of the queen check on a4
um i think that she's gonna win the game but she
has to see that idea yeah she might play c3 which
is very london style but uh yes good point that's
also very good just push that c pawn and see the
see the wing check although queen two is very nice
as well very dangerous yeah queen takes a6 i like
that just as much as c3 or c to be honest i didn't
know what she was going to play if not for moving
the c pawn i didn't even think that like she
would just sneak out get the pawn taken uh and
then and now now by the way e6 queen a6 the rook
is hanging oh man this could go downhill quickly
correct yeah yeah it could definitely
go downhill in a hurry for myth here um
uh if if uh if he doesn't find
a way to develop his king here
22 is a very very good move just you got no
checks you got no captures attached to weak pieces
yeah so i mean i think for myth it's very
hard to play here very very hard to play here
um f6 again yeah but see the problem with f6
here is i think we've told a lot of the streamers
especially the ones who are very new to the
game the idea of pushing a pawn like the f pawn
is very shaky and now pokemon should see queen
takes pawn here on a6 yeah because the queen is
on the diagonal it's eyeing the pawn so i think
she will say that she can take yeah the dangerous
thing is that now of course smith wants to
move his bishop and i see him kind of like
you know he's ready to go but he pushed that pawn
now his rook is not guarded and she takes it uh oh
um okay yeah she could go here no my my king takes
it actually never mind i'm trolling um but the
rook don't forget about the rook my rook is under
threat good because of that move she just made
nice
about to move the rook over
now if pokemate says queen a4 she's going to win
is a nice move as well to trade off some rooks
and go down to the end of the board yes this
is actually an insane position because white
is only up a pawn but it's plus nine because of
how weak the king is uh rook b1 like icarus said
or look for the check don't go queen c6 do not
trade queens do not and even then maybe you're
still going to win but don't trade queens so queen
yeah i think rook b1 and queen a4 both moves are
very cleanly winning here um i think rook b1
is actually a very natural move to play here
i think it's a very natural move to to try and
create checkmates also i know pokemon likes
likes the background checkmate theme so
i can see rook b1 and she could see like
oh no no oh that's a huge mistake i mean i think
she's still going to win the game but that is a
huge mistake by pokeman but myth is clicking his
king like he's clicking his king he he doesn't
even see back backward queen right now oh wait
no no he just saw it he just clicked this queen
these guys are terrifying me with their clicking
you just look at his screen right now it's it's a
no but he sees the bishop guards the queen is
he gonna trade oh he played oh oh oh oh no oh
oh no no no no oh no oh he saw that he was
guarded but he didn't and look at pokeman
oh my gosh
she is taking her time i don't think she's gonna
miss it one thing that pokeman has been really
good at is checkmating pattern she's done a lot
of puzzles and i do think she's gonna see it
the only reason she might not see it is she
might see the fork with knight takes pawn
and just trade the queen yes she might
play queen to and no no no no just know
that was clean and now she's going to feel bad
because she spent so much time she's going to
be like oh my god i had me no you're just
not sure though you're like it looks like it
it looks like it and you await the little sign
you await the little sound from.com that goes
because sometimes you do it exactly yeah
and the sound doesn't go off and you're like
uh oh oh my bad my not bad i uh i play with
sounds off like a madman that's why sometimes i
don't know when they move and i lose
on time when i'm talking to my chat but
impressive game no from pokey that was good very
impressive i mean queen c6 was not i think i mean
it would have been better with queen a4 queen d7
but nonetheless a very impressive start from here
here in this first match of the uh of the the
bracket stage also big shout out to ludwig who
who um who i feel like in the first podcast was
saying i hate chess it's such a hard game and now
i see ludwig tweeting 10 minutes ago saying i love
chess so um yes did you hear that ludwig was such
a fan of the game yes i remember when i when when
we were younger it was uh it was very cool to like
write a facebook status like ah chess is so i hate
chess or you know chess is the best then it would
always get a lot of you know a lot of attraction
no it's it's yeah you're the best and then it's
like you nerd go back go go back and yes
don't remind me of middle school man i was
just forgetting about it and now all right well
on that note congrats to pokey on the first win
uh myth has to strike back now with the white
pieces might be our last game of the day might
have a blitz playoff we'll be right back i really
like her have that [ __ ] that hurts that hurted
are you on mod to bet no
gg that was uh yeah i really i really oofs their
damage
wait why did i castle here instead why did i
move my rook forward i could have just done
i just wasn't paying it oh man that's embarrassing
as well i actually had a great
opportunity to castle i threw down
all right we go next game
only big problem is that you're way too passive gg
though well i mean i don't think that's a problem
well not that it's a problem but it's like
i felt like i was trying to find things to
like make me positive i wasn't trying to just
go even but i guess sometimes it's not bad to
go even and i think that's my mistake which
is being too passive at the end of the day
you guys are right actually i guess i don't
think about it as passiveness i just think
like i'm trying to go for other things
instead of going for like simple trades
that could potentially do more for me in
the long run and put me in a better position
you cannot castle right side
yeah let's analyze real quick holy [ __ ] that was
yeah that would have been a good trade
i have to go castle this way whoops my
bad
like i should have went for this too dude
and i needed to move oh my god i knew
i should have taken it dude [ __ ]
i lose here as well no the best okay the best
is literally just take and he takes and then
welcome back everyone to punch
champs three presented by grip6
it's been a long day it's been a
long day and uh for our final match
pokey struck first in a spot where it was clean it
was just a small slip up worth the queen trade but
she finds the mate and uh you know i saw myth
analyzing his game afterward i hope he doesn't
get too frustrated because you know hikaru
like we talk about people in their seating
it was really rough for him he was in maybe the
worst group of all the players maybe michelle
had it bad too which group was he in again he
had nico he had nico benji and sardosh like oh
oh he was in he was in the group of death yeah
yeah that's actually really harsh um yikes that
that that's actually brutal yes yeah i was gonna
say it's like you know for nico for example i as
i said if she had been another group i think
she had a shot but she was in the group with
with a benjamin sardosh and i felt like nico was
was really strong so yeah myth got really unlucky
in the groups um they played three players who all
could have easily been in the championship bracket
so he was in the he was in the group of death i
mean the group of death uh actually sorry to cut
you off or to interject again but isn't that the
um isn't that football world cup some sort of like
isn't that a league of legends term too something
related to tsm oh maybe but i know that like you
you can be in a group of death and like knockouts
be in in football in like the world cup right
it's world cup yeah yeah uh you have some crazy
teams and like three great teams and only two
will make it or whatever i don't even man i uh
yeah i know i mean i feel bad for this certainly
it's been really really rough um because it's
true i think if you look at the other groups
for example the group with michelle karen mr
beast there were groups like that or no sorry
mr beast and code miko there could he maybe
he could have ended up in a slightly softer
group so he got really unlucky um ending up in the
group of death but again he has a chance here he's
he's played well and he could have been in that
first game against pokemon yes well no he he for
him and michelle uh michelle before pogchamps
knew zero like literally zero and i remember
uh we had an introductory just like phone call
conversation she was like what would be the
final step of my challenge accepted like would
i play the beth harmon bots like what would i do
um i think our contract ended with them so
we don't even have them anymore so i can't
even talk about them scratch that but uh you know
and i said pog champs but it's going to be tough
but hicaro i never thought it would be that tough
the lowest rated player in her group was like 900
i mean yeah i think it's been it's been amazing
the grind uh and this is something that i actually
i spoke a little bit with ludwig about uh everyone
everyone i think thinks there's some magic beef
that i have with a lot of obviously i don't um but
i was talking to ludwig and it's true that kind of
in the in this event it seems like some of the
players they really put their heads down and
they've been grinding very hard and that doesn't
just apply to like the star doshes of the world or
um or the xqc's of the world but like even some
of these newcomers like pokeman for example or
michelle care they've really been putting in a lot
of time and effort so um it's kind of the natural
sort of effect i think you see some streamers have
more time others have commitments it's all it's
all in the streamers in terms of how much time
they they put in yeah and the communities right
because i feel like pokey like she it was positive
and she had good coaching and everything and i
feel like it can be tough like i think myth even
has struggled with it i mean when he plays he gets
he gets like caught up but sometimes i see
some of the crazy stuff in there like you
know why are you doing this go back to
you know first person shooter i'm like
oh it's it's brutal we're like well i mean as
as uh as i think pokemon put it so eloquently
in her tweet she said i'll i won't say the word on
stream but she said basically if people are gonna
say something about me it might as well you know
eff it and do whatever i want to do so i think
some communities have been much more supportive
than others and uh it's like yeah it's it's
it's difficult i've seen some of the stuff in this
chat um but again you know we are all streamers at
the end of the day and um i think we all have
to deal with that on some level or another
oh yeah uh absolutely i mean when you play
auto chess how good are you at autos just now
i know they don't pay us for oh i love auto
chess oh there you go but my community they
they they know that i'm going to be a paper
at anything except shots so they they've like
they've accepted that um so they've been pretty
mild towards yeah the the the other day i hit
my peak sr in overwatch and i think that if i
ever get to diamond i might stream it again but
not with voice comes on because the last time i
did that i almost got to s so ah well but i mean
if you do that then half your chat is going to be
like oh you're so bad at this like go back to us
yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean and i don't mean i
mean like they're literally going to say that
right um and i think at some point it gets hard
because you just want to enjoy yourself and have
a good time now pokemon finds knight takes d4
here i'm gonna be ridiculously impressed yeah
knight d4 is crazy having said that hikaro if she
scans for captures it's the only capture she has
and then she has to find knight f3 true true so
that's where the thought process comes in knight
d4 bishop d7 and then whoops suicide factory yeah
does xqc come up with a name for in-between move
i don't think so you you mean the in-between
and then that you take and then you take yeah
yeah i don't know i don't think so but i think
you're gonna now he's probably gonna watch his
broadcast he's gonna come up with something
really random out of the blue for that i'm sure
actually levy i got the idea you know you know
what we need to do we need to uh publish a book
once xcc comes with a few more terms we just need
to publish our book um with all the new chess
terms and we just sell it and if every person
on twitch buys it for like one buck we'll be
we'll both be worth like uh 100 million dollars
oh well oh that'll i mean that'll double your net
worth that will that will definitely uh you know
i had this idea but i think you were playing in
a tournament so i couldn't even share it with
you um it was gonna be like you know chess for
five heads i made like a video way back in
the day before queen's gambit before and it
was uh before juicer before any of that stuff so
yeah yeah it'll be a nice big coloring book and
a picture book not coloring i'm not going to color
it um chad you'll buy it right i guess i'll buy it
well yeah of course we will buy it once once
they've made all their money on amc and gme
um yeah they will we'll do like a hikaru chest
never has the drops they don't have the drops
you know like in video games so do drops on your
free book and then there you go amazon listen up
all right we got a business proposal um mitt's got
to win this game though so he's got to not trade
too many pieces okay i like c4 i don't think it's
a bad move but dc4 knight c4 b5 and then he has
to find and you know the one good thing i would
say for myth here is that i think he has some
experience in this because he i believe in the
in the first match he played against benji fishy
i think benji also played a french and i think it
was an exchange french if i'm not mistaken so he
does have some idea of the pawn structure which
i think is actually very important at this level
yes exactly to be able to make progress with uh
with pawns all right she takes and he takes back
it could be a weakness but open rook maybe center
reinforced um he's gotta not be so down on himself
like he's gonna hang b5 he's not gonna see that
but he needs to play knight d6 just keep it cool
okay good so far no she's gonna see this probably
maybe maybe she'll play queen f6 that's also like
a aggressive move yeah i think so far myth
has a great position i think when i look at
the position that he has it's um it's about as
good of a position as he could get he's castled
he's developed nothing really is under attack so
we're in a stage where both players have to come
up with plans and i think that trying to come
up with plans here this is the first step um
in terms of trying to uh win the game you have to
be able to get out of the opening stage counselor
can develop and then worry about coming up with
long-term plans but if you can't get out of the
opening stage like in the previous game that myth
had um that's you're going to lose very early
and even for xqc we saw it um you know against
charlie and a couple of other matches where if
he didn't get out of the opening stage he would
just lose right away so it is very very critical
um and i think in terms of myth he should try to
come up with this idea like bishop c2 and queen
d3 and line up the battery towards pokemon's king
yes something over here it's a game filled with
different ideas uh but it can be difficult i mean
it could be difficult to stack it all together
because just the kind of thing like bishop c2 only
makes sense if you combine it with other moves
otherwise you're never going to play it and you
know you might just take on d6 because it's like
an option and then you have to find something else
you can't just trade everybody all the time um
we'll see what he comes up with it's a big
moment i'm i'm pumped for myth rookie one okay
good move by myth i i like what he's doing
if he doesn't make blunders i think um
i think i think that's the other thing if you
don't give up like bishops or knights for free
uh then then you have much better chances so
as long as you miss the obvious blunders you're
you're looking good and i think myth has a great
position so far uh which is why i bet bet on him
okay bishop g4 again he needs to not panic keep
it cool h3 and then she has to go bishop h5 and
then keep the attention i would love to actually
you know it's not the best move but i'd love to
see miss play d5 here and line up that uh that
pin on the diagonal and i think pokeman sees it
did you see the way pokemon her eyebrows
popped up i think she saw d5 was a move
maybe now i wish we saw the uh the screener had
the had the the mic but we don't sadly but that's
all right um and you know i was also thinking
one other thing that's really amazing is you'll
see that a lot of these a lot of these players i
think maybe it's just more competitive they are
but when they make a mistake you'll see
these expressions like benji yesterday
i mean he kept it together but you could totally
tell that when he started the first game against
negrano started to slip away he wanted to rage
you could just see that he was that passion that
into it um i think seeing the expressions
from from quite a few of these players is uh
it's really amazing yeah they they want it you
know and they've been working and it sucks because
sometimes you put in a lot of work and it all of
i i've said this i would hate to learn chess as an
adult because i don't know how difficult it would
be i've tried to learn other things like it's
it's it's so tough and it can be very frustrating
so you've got to be ready to make a lot of
mistakes and lose a lot because a lot of us want
to be efficient with our learning we want to do
well but you are going to lose so much more
in the beginning before before you're going
to win so well i mean i think that's why chess is
that's also why chess is such a great game because
you have that learning curve and it's such a long
process i think in many ways it teaches you how
to learn and how kind of how to lose and how to
persevere and overcome it and um sort of find that
motivation within yourself and i think xqc oh no
oh no no no no no what does she think about three
yeah i know when pokeman sees that you can just
tell the way she put her fingers together that
was also another tale telltale sign you can tell
that she could tell something was wrong with that
yeah i i wish i was uh the barrier oh no just
just that expression you could tell she sensed
that something was wrong there shout out to
all those working hard both on and off the
camera to make chess more enjoyable and amazing
for the fans and the participants that's out of
the personal account not the company account
by the way just in case anybody you know uh
danny hope you're good thanks for letting me
sub in for you today uh i wish i was bringing
that news at a better moment danny could not have
picked a more tense moment here oh man and brutal
at least he goes king f1 though he's going to
run the king to the center yes um yeah but this
is really harsh really difficult situation here
for myth his king is under attack doesn't really
have any counter play it's like basically the
texture of the position with all these pieces
they're no attacks for white and black has all the
ideas and i think in general when you end up in
such situations it's very very hard to play yeah
i wonder if i i actually have a feeling if anybody
in the event pokey is the most cerebral who would
just make a draw because she knows that she wins
like i don't know she just she seems like she
kind of works out the details she'll play queen
h2 if she needs to and she'll repeat if she needs
to but we'll see she might just be confident that
she will find queen h2 and uh with the next move
um however if she does not find queen shoe and
myth can play rook to h1 the game could swing very
quickly because even though myth is behind by a
pawn um actually queen h4 my queen h4 is actually
a better move so king e2 there's knight takes deep
does she see that i don't know if she sees
it but queen h4 is the best move objectively
because now you can't run with the king on
queen h3 if you go king f1 king e2 king d3
um so queen h4 is actually the best move here
just objectively the best move and i do think
there is a good chance that pokemon will actually
realize that she also you can see a slight sort of
smile on her face as well and that kind of told me
that she has some idea there's some way to maybe
finish this match very quickly here like queen g5
or rookie six are both very strong i mean she she
uh also i think is experienced enough to know
the concept of the rook lift if she just plays
rookie six wow yeah better than ludwig what can i
say ludwig i mean in that moment against charlie
couldn't find it but here's pokemane yeah and he
had two a little bit harder and finding finding
the rook lifts and by the way the rook h6 and rook
d5 there so um no rookie six is very clean and
this is over in a move if rook h1 rook g6 yeah
you know i mean i think this is the thing uh i i
i don't think we've seen it because i don't
think pokeman has been been playing chess or
studying chess on stream but to me it's very clear
that she has been putting a lot of time because
these concepts like rookie six rook g6 just not
it's just not a normal concept to find and takes
time and even someone like ludwig who has put in a
lot of time um uh studying the game like even that
it's just if you if you haven't seen it it doesn't
come right away then um it's very hard and for
everybody who's wondering no they're i mean there
is no there there's everyone wants to create some
magic beef with ludwig there is no magic beef um
only magic beef is there's a waffle beef right
but there's no magic beef um no there's no magic
beef but uh there's uh there's wagyu and that's
pretty damn close so no but i mean that's that's
my new business idea i'm gonna create a new brand
uh magic beef there's already impossible beef or
impossible meat or whatever and beyond meat i just
create magic meat that's all that either sounds
terrifying or like the next billion dollar company
like i'm gonna see it go public your your
stock ticker will be beef and it's i don't
know if that probably exists already but what
a meme ticker anyway all right okay um yeah
okay okay she plays queen g5 she did have rook
g6 and that was lights out so but it's not over
now it's not oh queen e3 never mind did she
see that i mean this is just so brutal it's so
i think the thing that's really been
frustrating or difficult to watch with myth
is that he ended up in a group where he was he
was clearly or it was over match he was in the
group of death with three very strong players
and so you know when i look at like rubius for
example who he actually finally got a win today
even though he lost niko he could have won any
one of those games and with myth it just feels
like he's been really unlucky and out of all the
games he's played he's the one player who i feel
like has unfortunately not had any any any legit
or realistic winning chance at any of the games so
it's very very difficult um and i feel bad for men
yeah it's tough because to be honest the growth
that he's that he's shown in a month's time it's
very similar to michelle like michelle's
like 500. and that's fine the problem is
you have a brutal field man you have people who
just maybe put in 10 more hours than you and that
makes all the difference in those 10 hours they
got 10 different tactical situations and they find
themselves more confident yeah no it's definitely
true um and it's just yeah it's pretty it's pretty
tough to see here i feel really bad for myth
just very unlucky with the groups now pokeyman
plays queen takes pawn i was going to say the one
thing i would say about pokemane is i think in her
group it's not going to be that big of an issue
um but she seems to have this predilection towards
trying to trade down when she's ahead by one or
two pawns um and i think that in this this this
sort of this this match and probably this bracket
won't matter but sometimes you really do have to
go for the kill you cannot be so materialistic
and just try to grab pawns and trade it all down
yeah i totally agree and right right now is a
good chance for myth to play a move like queen c2
but tough to see that right you got
definitely very very difficult um to see
and then he's gotta hope pokey does
what she did against xqc that was so
so rough to watch because she had it
oh but he's lining it up even if it's not c2 it's
a great idea lining up the checkmate and again
pokemon with the obvious tell you can you can see
how she's looking she's like what is what's going
on here what is the idea and unfortunately because
it's such a weird move i think it's pretty obvious
what the idea is on h7 okay well she blunders
it okay it's still winning for pokeman yeah
wow that's actually lucky i mean if she had moved
the other rook over it would have been mate like
damn she's gotta go here unfortunately the white
king is still too open here so pokeman should
find a checkmate um but that being said
at least smith gets something and i think
come on yeah i'm happy i'm the one checking
phil's like yeah guys take the bishop
you go straight ahead go take
it oh you want another one
i like it yeah would you look at that as two i
could play this game too take the rook come on
all right come on don't take the pawn there's
a rook on the other side i like queen h4 just
for the yes just for the idea of making a
check and hoping that pokemon won't see it
uh to be honest no don't touch your rook no don't
touch your rook please don't touch the rook on a1
please just move your queen yeah he's um okay good
he finally sees it so i actually could see he he
actually clicked on the rook on a1 when he was
almost like going to play rook d1 so at least he
takes the rook yes they do this thing mm-hmm they
do this thing they tickle the pieces and i'm just
like all right take the no don't touch the rick
and then i'm like okay okay yeah pokey's gotta
check him she's gotta change it's all it's all
good um unless you unless you're xqc where like
you automatically your first instinct is the right
one you click the right piece you got the right
move and then you start clicking all over the
place and becoming a you know doubting uh daniel
what kind of a name would be best associated
with a doubter doug i don't know doug
i'm not every doug i've ever met i
i didn't really i hope i'm not like
forgetting i i i i mean you're supposed to
say aren't you supposed to use the same letter
well yeah doug what's wrong with her doubting
doug go here take the pawn yeah i don't know
douglas doubting donald trump human is a
douglas doubting drake i don't know but anyway
we'll see what happens yes queenie two is
literally made i love how hype myth is he
has no idea of oh and she takes on b2 see this
is what i'm saying she gets way too materialistic
when she sees something she like this is the
second game she's probably gonna win anyway
but she's way too materialistic in situations
where um where it's not required like she doesn't
go for the checkmate she doesn't go for the kill
she doesn't look for the checks immediately um in
kind of the way that i i think she's good which
it's it's it's like in the first game it didn't
matter because she won anyone we need to take out
this night trying to trade down taking the pawns a
couple of pawns in this game really unnecessary
yes right now it might still go in her favor
but oh all right uh oh oh oh no but now this
invites queenie two now queenie she should see
queenie two because it's a it's a check um it's a
tactic puzzle yes uh if she takes a2 i i would not
be shocked if she takes a2 as well but i think she
kind of has to realize she is behind here material
uh myth has two rooks on the board and she only
has a rook and a night so i think because of that
she should look for it but again that's
what i'm saying she goes queen takes pawn
um getting way too materialistic
not looking for chucks and as the
saying goes you miss 100 of the checks
that you don't you don't you don't make
if you don't check you can never check me i don't
know if she if she's lucky or brilliant but queen
d8 is made if the night isn't there so exactly
yep oh wait like walking on on a tight rope and
like if she moves the night now thinking it's
hanging if she does not look at queenie two
mm-hmm just looking if she doesn't look for checks
it's very very dangerous it's it's it isn't she
mated on queensy seven like king of maybe not
almost almost definitely very very close here
she has to find the check and she hasn't
found one in like seven moves so yikes
and they've been there she's just not
looking for them she's just picking
up pawns but they're not relevant the
king is relevant the rooks are relevant
gotta go for a check
dense moment here she doesn't give
a check she might straight up lose
yeah i think i think there's a good chance she
will lose if she does not make a check here
because all myth wants is c7 it's insane and she
finds it wow but is she going to take the rook
or she going to make it what i didn't see before
so it's kind of 50 50 when she went rookie six
idea was to make a check so we'll kind of see
um what happens i would guess she takes the rook
but yeah yeah i mean she would take
the rook uh because it's just it's
an obvious free rook and you know the rooks
and the queens are really really worth a lot
yeah the rook maneuver
at this point is decisive again she needs to just
spot it and she'll be okay but okay there it is
rookie two
myth smith has two legal moves so
there it is and now you take the rook yes and that
she's gonna spot because she's been snap taking
rooks yeah uh was that a pre-move maybe maybe he
wants to move against queen d6 check and play f4
i don't know that was very
strange but anyway at any rate um
uh myth cannot win he only has one queen he
can make a lot of checks with the queen but
there's no way he's getting a check
made here with a lone queen on the board
um yeah she has a queen she has a rook uh okay
queen f1 i don't love is there any outside way
that white can make a checkmate here with the
queen of the pond is what i'm trying to figure out
somehow the rook covers everything important you
know it's like just covering all the right spots
the other thing i would say the reason that
pokemon will win here will not lose this game
either is she does know the concept of
trading down she knows how to make some
of the basic checkmates like the king and
queen versus king she has that memorized
king and rook as well like she's got some of these
basic mates down so one thing that pokeman is very
good at and it's something i've noticed like
sardosh and benji also do very well and it's
one of these characteristics is they do not get
tunnel vision like if they know there's a forest
way to win a certain setup they will go for it
every time they will ignore the other half of the
board if they if they can and they'll just know
the technique so it is one thing that pokey um
pokey does very well so that's why i do think
she is not in any danger i'm in this position
yeah that check is a bit annoying because you
already look at the time look at the time that's
the only thing myth has he's got a queen and time
and that's that that's his pr oh oh yikes okay
queen takes knight uh don't go don't keep don't
keep going forward you just go okay she goes back
and there's no back there's no ice skater
because even if you go to f8 or f8 dude
this is terrifying like yeah it's almost
like there's no checkmate because white
would need to get the queen to g5 oh
my gosh pokemon it's just copy still
it's not checkmate still i know king e4 is still
not made but you don't go forward oh my it's wait
how is it a draw exactly there's probably some
repetition here with like queen c4 queen c3 c4
you can check on c4 c3 and if f5 you go f7 c4 you
do the yoyo oh yo-yo between f7 c4 and c4 c3 it's
just a classic yo-yo and it's like the yo-yo where
you uh what do you call it i don't know what you
call where did that even come from yo-yo around
the moon i don't know anyway whatever um it just
said yo-yo yeah because it's a yo-yo you see it's
like one end up back i know yeah it's not like
you're right i used to play the yo-yo
but i don't know what you call that that
anyway whatever okay is that an xqc thing or
you just made that up i just made that all back
beautiful beautiful okay you made that out sorry
you we just witnessed history you are the first
grand master to ever call a maneuver like that
a yo-yo so it's uh but myth takes mitt doesn't
realize that he's in grave danger the scissor
or the ladder sorry check on g2 and go queen h1
yeah um it's time for essentially
one also yeah you see is it
oh wait all the ambulance okay why'd you
you got us all the way over here for this
well she she really got my hopes up you know that
i that's so disrespectful dude that is so rude
she really did she really she's like you know
what let's play this whole thing out dude
let's play this whole thing out so i
can make him feel like he has a chance
just so i can take it all away from him
at the very end this is cyberbullying
i can't believe it
i know i know it's made
oh i was sweating at the end there i
won't lie that was very very intense pokey
pokey gets the win that first one was mildly
less stressful than this one this one yeah
this one got really spicy at the end yeah that
was uh that was crazy but she does take the win
we're going to get the players to join us
on call for our final interview of the day
park champs 3 presented by grip6 it's
our final break we'll be right back
oh well that was a good one that was a good one
boys well i wanted to review the
chess games that we had yet to uh
review because we never got a chance to
but i think i have something
more fun we could review
have you guys heard of the game rocket league
there it is there it is makes it look like
he's lost control now if you guys haven't
um this is what i was doing this morning when
i was preparing for uh logic ex i think he car
roasted me earlier but i was i was playing a bit
of a of rocket league because i had a show match
versus atrial for 1250 um match of the century
atriac the ankle snatch reverse a lot of the small
um let's just skip ahead here what
we've seen so far is is really
really incredible let's just skip a little bit
further ahead oh one zero me i'm the blue side
kind of a laser
now you might be wondering ludwig i thought
it was supposed to be like an even match
what ended up happening well i'm going to show
you this unreleased footage because i did a local
recording during all of this this is the funniest
part when i was playing atriac earlier today
in that exact moment that we were just
looking at for those first three goals
one second the video's auto
rewinding and i don't know why
why does the video auto rewind
uh anyway the point is though
oh it's because my controller's plugged in
so i had a problem with my controller that you
just saw the lb button is automatically pressed
so the scoreboard was open for
the entire first three goals
oh my god that was stressful let's try and uh
and i still went 3-0 on him how is he so bad
and i wasn't sure if it was the game
or not so i opened up the discord and
asked if it was the real game
what's going on is he [ __ ] with me
he this is the real game
anyway it was 12-1 at the end of it uh which is a
new record for both of us in the biggest blowout
ever in the smug playoff match so shout out to us
boys shout out to us we have the world record now
surely we'll have to put
that on youtube during break
anyway
game two i did not use my boost at all
then game three i didn't use a jump
that is true i figured it would be
weird to just 12-1 stomp your homie
better swag on him than tell
in front of 30 000 people
welcome back everyone to our final interview of
the day joined by both players congratulations
obviously uh pokey how uh how did that match
go expectations versus reality how was that
um to be honest i have not been
practicing enough chess and my
chest vision was quite off today that's
why i had to keep putting on the goggles
thought that was trash um we thought you
were like we thought you were like zero oh
no no that's me like looking for the right
move you know that's what i was missing
yeah i'll open up my goggles next time don't worry
thanks but yeah i think it went i mean i'm glad i
won but myth has been practicing pretty well he
could have taken it for sure but you know i got
like 200 rating on him so i need to win right
that's the expectation i mean yeah we've had uh
we've had all sorts of crazy matches so rating
hasn't always but yes i mean i guess going in uh
you would be the favorite myth um we he speak
speaking of you know favorites we were saying
you were in the group of death in the group in
the early stage right like did you feel that way
how did that how's your chest been since you kind
of kicked this whole process off in january uh up
to now the group of the group of death yeah we
thought that it was kind of insane with sardosh
and benji and um overall like i've just been
having a great time playing chess uh i don't think
i've put in as much time as i would uh have liked
to overall there's a lot of things to work on and
to uh for me to do but overall like i think
this has been a really great introduction to
chess and i'm excited to like keep at it
you know and i think that's the important
thing that i'm getting out of this is like
you know i've become interested in this game
because of this event and because of you know
just the excitement around versing some of you
know some people like pokey and and nico and benji
and just the hype all around it so i definitely
want to you know move forward with it which i
think you know that's that's important for me
well hicaro we were uh we're kind of alluding to
that right i mean specifically just the practice
and the behind the scenes and how each creator
has to balance it pokey how much practice are
you were you still doing off stream behind the
scenes like if you without giving away prep
because you're still in the event right so yeah
i prior to actual matches i'll usually do like uh
a small coaching sesh but to be honest
i haven't been actually playing a lot or
getting that experience which i think if anything
is probably the most important thing um but i also
don't want to like stress myself you must play
three hours of chess every day i'm just glad
that i think you know i'll get better with
time i think myth did really really well and
as he said i'm just glad to feel like i kind of
picked it up as a hobby hopefully for life yeah
hopefully for life indeed takara any uh any any
anyone i just want to say i think in in terms
of myth uh like when we said group of death like
the reason for saying that is that three of the
players who were in your original group stage two
of them are probably gonna i mean they're probably
the favorites to me in the final the champions
bracket nico has played ex extremely well and
she's had a lot of experience so we felt that
perhaps uh you didn't really have opportunities
in the way that you would have if you were in
other groups and then um and then today was it was
a struggle too but but overall i thought you had
some opportunities you played wellness match today
and you just keep your head up and um and if
you just play even if it's just casually you
will improve so i think that's that's sort
of what i would say is don't be discouraged
by what has happened newbie group next time and
it's me and myth in it yup straight to the top
yeah but uh no yeah for sure this is it's
been extremely like motivating and even like
playing against these like i guess like the
juggernaut players and the group and still being
able to like you know make some things happen or
it being like me just not seeing one move to it
being like a really really close match or like me
getting even ahead just off of missing one move
is really like obviously it could be really the
motivating but it's something to learn from and
it's uh it's motivating also in the same exact
way so i want to keep it up well thank you both
you keep referring to like the newbie group or
or not having expectations now uh you probably
are one of the favorites to potentially make
to the final at least the consolation bracket
i was curious you you mentioned um in a previous
interview that hoffo had been cheering you on i
was wondering um like has she been giving you
advice has it just been like just good luck uh
what what what have she kind of said
to you if you don't mind sharing that
honestly just always being really supportive
cheering me on she also introduced me to
someone who helped her gm hess and he has been
just like so helpful um doing some like small
coaching sessions off stream and just also helping
me have the right attitude towards the games
you know i'm here for a good time not a long time
so yeah yeah honestly on that note if either of
you ever wants to get like hyped up or like pumped
up and motivated back up in the vaude and watch
what logic said because like he said the most
inspirational like five minutes it was it was it
was amazing he's like i'm gonna get off this call
and you know i'm gonna go back to you know my wife
and kid uh you know whatever whatever grind it is
that you're on just go right back to it and you're
here like you said for a good time not a long time
so but pokey on that note you probably want to
win it now right because you keep on winning now
in this consolation bracket so you're we'll see
well um thank you to you both of you for the match
uh myth hope to see you playing chess on stream in
the future and pokey will see you for the semis
thank you for having us have a good one bye guys
we uh we're gonna end the day with what our
consolation bracket looks like we've only got
two because we're still waiting for tubbo and
code miko and then in two days we have beast
and michelle and we probably have that in two
days because of the scheduling of everything
but also maybe beast is in the mountains
somewhere filming i'm sure mr beast is probably
recording his next big you know multi-million
dollar uh video probably uh which will get you
know the classic 50 million views on youtube
so i'm sure he's very he's a very busy guy
um and uh it's going to be exciting though because
i think that's a pretty balanced matchup between
mr beast and michelle carrie i think it could go
either way jimmy has had his moments where he's
won some games he's also had some unfortunate
moments as well michelle she played really
well against rayne wilson who's still in the
championship bracket so she could win two it's
gonna be a very exciting match of course tomorrow
we have taboo against code miko which should be
exciting as well on that note we're going to take
just one final look at the champions bracket and
you know higher that's kind of crazy these guys
have two days to prep they got tomorrow and friday
like that's more than more than some
gm's get you guys get a game a day off
so i hope we see some fire prep i hope we see
uh you know yeah i think i mean in terms of
consolation bracket it's just players should just
work on the things that they're they're missing
and i think like in pokeman's case she's a little
bit too materialistic at times instead of looking
to sort of attack and chuck made her opponent's
king um that could just be a defensive reflex
uh but i think like mr beast he he when he got
out of the opening with good positions he was
doing very well in all of his games even against
ludwig so i think for him the opening should be
his priority just try to get out get to like move
10 um and go from there and michelle i think just
keep grinding she got some great positions against
rayne um and and she's she's been trying very
hard so i think she's uh she's she has a great
chance as well but it'll be exciting to watch
yeah tomorrow uh we we already know that matchup
that's kind of the uh the final sign-off moment
it was uh it's been an intense day of games
i mean it yeah it's it's been crazy i mean i
think we saw charlie i mean he was the winner of
the consolation bracket yeah one put up a great
fight against rain but came a little bit short
um very tense match i think the logic ludwig
match also really really close one one the the
final blitz game logic missed the mate and two
ludwig ends up with it ends up going around the
other way and then he has his mate in two right
away so really really exciting pokemon myth as
well um and there was one other match right was it
what was the other one there was a fourth one
i'm blanking it's been a long day i'm forgetting
uh well no there was nikko and rubius in the
morning that was the other one right which also
um very very close match that could have been uh
that could have been or no it was one one right
it was one more it was nico that also went to
a blitz game so really really intense matches
all around and i think the fact that we're seeing
these close matches no real mismatches especially
the fact that it's been so competitive has been
really the biggest change i think in pogchamps
three versus the other pog champs uh where it's
really close everyone is trying really really
hard and it's been a lot of fun to watch so far
and it's only going to get more intense as we
reach the semis and then the finals as well it's
been uh it's been awesome oh my uh sorry my uh my
camera died because i booted up uh i booted up
obs that's that's that's that's what happens oh
are you streaming that's why yeah yeah yeah so
i'm gonna be i've got the raid to yourself yep
yes exactly uh it's it's not me it's the mods but
uh listen just a shout out to chat uh shout out
to all the you know commentators on earlier today
everybody working behind the scenes to make this
uh event so awesome and uh we'll see you back
tomorrow for just one match-up just one matchup
and that's uh that's tubbo versus uh code miko
park champ three presented by grip six we out bye
three two one
black
three two one here we go
so
let's go
get out take it out
now
oh